this is a production of Cornell
University so basically I like to set
the stage first um so kind of a a very
colorful kind of Technic graph um but
basically what this is showing is global
carbon dioxide emissions this is time
across the bottom um think you can all
see by the Pink Arrow this is where we
are in kind of the spaghetti of all
these lighter lines these are possible
Pathways that people came up with that
Society is going to evolve in terms of
their carbon dioxide emissions so
basically the point that I want to make
is the red line here is essentially the
path that we're on it's sometimes called
the business as usual scenario and
really what it's saying is here we are
we're emitting about nine um gigatons of
carbon per year uh in
2014 and as we move out actually not too
far this is not even midcentury uh we're
basically doubling that so we're
basically set to double our carbon
dioxide emissions in a very very short
period of time 30 years um also notice
that this dash line that I put across is
basically I guess I was off a little bit
that's basically um current day
emissions and really all of these other
lines are above that there's only a few
cases that Dro below that so really no
matter what scenario you pick we're
basically in the next 30 or 40 years uh
destined to emit more carbon dioxide
than we do today it's only these very
very uh unlikely scenarios that drop us
down you know we're going to have to
have some major technological
breakthrough um Society the world in
general including not only the United
States but China and India are going to
have to drastically reduce their carbon
dioxide emissions if we hope to be on
this line um and if your eyes are really
good basically even though this is the
ipcc estimated business as usual we're
actually above that trajectory so we
have a higher spe than that so uh not
really a good picture here uh for
setting the
stage what does that mean basically what
that means is if we look at a Global
Perspective we're on the road to a world
that looks like this by the end of the
century looks really really red what
this is indicating here um I'm in degree
C across the Arctic average temperatures
that are 11 12 13° uh warmer SE warmer
than they are today and if we're maybe
more interested in our neck of the woods
we're in the area here of 8 or 9 or 10°
C warmer than we are today uh notice if
you look at this map uh everybody is
orange or red uh nobody is blue the
whole world warms um if I look at this
map over here this is actually that see
if I can go back um that's actually more
or less this scenario here in blue okay
so this is kind of a pie in the sky boy
I wish we could get here type scenario
and whoops wrong way even if we do that
this map is particularly you know it's
mostly red so even if we reduce the
emissions to that extent um the Artic
here is going to be warming about four
or 5 Dees uh C uh New York is on the
order of one or two deg SE so we're
locked into a certain amount of warming
even if we stop carbon dioxide today the
climate system has such inertia the
warming of the oceans and things like
that the residual carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere were locked into a certain
amount of
War all right know I find this to be a
particularly kind of compelling graph to
kind of just say oh my God we're we're
in trouble here we have to we have to do
something we have to adapt we have to
mitigate we have to modify our ways um
the blue line here is the observational
record of temperature uh for Central New
York basically a grid box from a climate
model and the red and the yellow graphs
are two carbon dioxide emission
scenarios so basically the red is the
higher emission scenario basically again
doubling CO2 by mid-century almost
quadrupling it by the end of the century
and the yellow um isn't quite that Pie
in the Sky really low scenario it's more
of a modest scenario it basically puts
us where we end up to you know basically
same CO2 emissions uh today in a 100
years as we are today goes up a little
bit mid-century but then pops back down
okay so in the net we're accumulating
more carbon dioxide so we see that over
the next yeah 40 or 50 years these two
lines are right on top of one another
again an idea of the inertia in the
climate system what we do right away
doesn't really affect the climate until
you know basically 50 years out that's
when those lines start to diverge um so
again we're locked into a certain amount
of climate change regardless of what
Society does but more importantly these
two arrows that come down kind of
hovering around
2050 represent the time when the new
record with climate change um basically
exceeds anything we've seen in the past
so what I mean these points if you look
at this point here and I guess this
point here these years are the coldest
years in this future record but these
years are warmer than any year we've
seen in the past so B basically
essentially we're in a new climate
regime the year that we would say is the
coldest oh my God it's cold here in New
York is actually warmer than any year
we've seen in the past based on these
projections from from two climate models
under two greenhouse gas CS so that's
not
again not something that we want to see
oops I forgot I
hadig um I'd also like to set the stage
you know I I work with a number of
people that are looking at climate
impact and things like that I end up
getting a a lot of questions like I mean
I know not too actually whenever I talk
to a fruit Grower's group or something
like that they say how is climate change
going to affect hail hail is the thing
that really you know does in my Apple
crop does in my peach crop we can put up
these hail Nets should that be the type
of thing um that we use for adaptation
so um spend a little bit of time to to
kind of describe this this is out of a
paper that uh myself and a few
colleagues put together in the Buon of
the AMS about a year ago uh what we did
was basically assessed um the ability to
detect different changes in the climate
system so really you can kind of view
this horizontal axis is how good are our
observations of these phenomena how well
can we look at the historical record and
say yeah there's been a trend in
temperature yeah there's been a trend in
precipitation and then the vertical axis
is really our understanding of the
knowledge you know kind of the cause and
effect type of thing so if I look up
here and I look at something like
precipitation or heat waves and cold
waves prolonged periods of hot and cold
our observational record of temperature
and precipitation is actually pretty
good so it falls up here and also our
understanding of the causes why an
increase in greenhouse gases would cause
temperature to go up precipitation to go
up is fairly good
um but yet I might contrast that to
these things that kind of fall on this
end of the scale things like hail or
tornadoes or ice storms um here we don't
have a very good OB obser observational
record you know basically ice storms are
events we have to you know the newspaper
has to report it somebody has to call
that in to the Weather Service before it
gets into the record so our historical
record of something like that is not
very good and likewise our understanding
how is climate change going to affect
something like that very very very very
poor in this case so I pick on Ice
storms because you know you can imagine
an ice storm you know even from your
experience of ice storms around here
it's really a narrow narrow band of
meteorological conditions that have to
come together just at the right time
just at the right levels of the
atmosphere to cause an ice storm so kind
of using a climate model to project
what's going to happen in that very very
narrow range of of condition
is very very hard so I would say well
you're out of luck if you really care
about this I mean I might as well take
again I'll pick on steuart Stuarts leads
where I don't know I'll throw the dart
at the dart board for things like this
but when we move up here to things like
temperature precipitation floods uh
droughts Cyclones know we have a better
understanding of why those are occurring
and and a good historical record of
seeing what those changes are um so
let's quickly look back at at what we've
seen in the record um we we've seen and
basically these the next set of figures
are basically specific to the Northeast
they come out of the national assessment
which has a chapter specific on the
northeast so if I look at average
temperatures no matter what season we're
in we have a trend it's a statistically
significant Trend in warming if I pick
on winter basically what we've seen is
um about a about a quarter of a degree
Fahrenheit Trend per decade so basically
over the 100 over 100 years that we've
had we've seen about 2 and half deg gar
warming ready the biggest trend is in
winter so the most warming we've seen
over the last 100 or so years has been
in the wayn if we look at extreme heat
so this is a metric of 4day average
temperature the 5year return period so
like the 98 percentile or something like
that not too interesting stream heat has
not changed very much in the Northeast I
can't tell you we have more heat Wings
the observational record doesn't support
that if I look at the opposite side same
type of metric but for cold spells in
Winter and here again a fairly
substantial a statistically significant
downward Trend so this idea of winter
warming um being more pronounced than
summer warming we look at the frostfree
season again a statistically significant
Trend um almost over this period of time
at least a week of lengthening of the
growing season and we'll see in those
projections that this is going to even
get longer than that you know we can
have a quite a nice growing season if if
climate change plays out or when climate
change plays out we look at total annual
precipitation again a statistically
significant upward Trend kind of looking
at this you know kind of again it's a
precipitation anomaly in inches so we've
increased over this 100 years on the
order of four or five inches that's
about 10% if we figure H against about
40 in of rain
here um where it really gets interesting
at least in my mind and a lot of my
research has focused on this is Extreme
rainfall okay so even though we have a
subtle increase in rainfall but what
really changes is the character of how
that rainfall comes so again kind of an
index so don't get too upset by the by
the seemingly small numbers here um this
is a derived value but we have a a very
significant actually almost if you look
at the numbers just in their magnitude
almost a doubling
of extreme precipitation events across
the Northeast so this is you know this
is the 5year return period daily
precipitation it's about 3-in rainfall
so basically we can expect the frequency
or we've seen the frequency of 2 3 4 in
rainfall events nearly double over the
last 100
years um I work with Bill fry a little
bit and I know Bill is always interested
in humidity so um again not the greatest
graph but from some work of post off and
I have done uh basically if we look this
is
spring um this is daytime hours this is
night time hours this set of graphs are
temperature so temperature goes up
everywhere basically and the big dots
that kind of have the the black borders
around them are statistically
significant Trends so kind of the size
of the dots represent the magnitude of
the trend but you look at the ones that
have kind of the black circles if your
eyes are good enough those are
statistically so pretty much red dots
over the entire country most of the
northern here statistically significant
spring Day Spring night middle graph is
dupoint so you can think of dupoint as
really a measure of the actual amount of
vapor that's in the atmosphere it's
essentially grams of water vapor in the
atmosphere and even oops going back and
even here primarily red dots everywhere
and most of them at least in the
northern TI statistically significant so
the actual amount of vapor in the
atmosphere has gone up relative
humidity in the last column is just that
it's relative it's how much vapor is in
the atmosphere relative to what the
atmosphere can hold so hopefully most
people in class or in class in in here
realize and I know Trevor will learn
this very quickly because he's in my
thermal class that as we heat the
atmosphere it holds more it can hold
more water vapor so it takes more water
vapor to saturate
and that's what relative humidity is
measuring it's measuring the ratio of
the amount of water vapor that's in the
atmosphere to the amount that the
atmosphere can hold before it saturates
so these two things taken in concert
with one another actually show a
decrease in relative humidity in most
places blue dots and actually over the
Northeast here a lot of circle dots
significant dos a drop in relative
humidity so basically the atmosphere
warms so much and even though the vapor
goes up it doesn't go up enough to cause
it to change it's its relative
saturation uh in terms of relative
humidity um we kind of see the same
thing in Spring maybe as we go to the
relative humidity column a little bit
different not much going on at night
here um and some spous actually positive
Trends across the Northeast so kind of
um this observational study don't ask me
why that happens in that case a lot of
EV for what might go on here in the
Midwest um in terms of this in terms of
the increase in Irrigation in crops so
adding another uh source of moisture
perhaps to the
atmosphere um and then last I think my
last slide for looking back is days with
snow cover and I know um this is to me
remarkable this is the number of days
that have at least an inch of snow on
the ground in Winter and if we look at
over a kind of an older graph but over a
30e period that that number of days is
deined by more than 30 years uh 30 days
so you know 30 days fewer during winter
when we have at least an inch of snow on
the
ground all right so what does the future
hold um and to say what the future holds
we need to ask a model okay and
unfortunately most meteorologists most
climatologists are more like Sheldon
from Big Bang so our models look more
like this than in the previous life so
lots and lots of
Ms um
and essentially these equations that go
into it's just a smattering of them
really the idea is if we look at the
climate system in this cartoonist
climate system all of these things we
need to basically depict represent
mathematically so not only you know the
amount of wherever it is um you know
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere but how
do changes in the sun's input vary
what's the chemist chemistry that's
going on in the atmosphere not only
between not only with CO2 but a whole
range of different gases uh aerosols
when do the volcanoes go off they have
an effect on the climate how does the
biosphere interact with the atmosphere
what happens in the cloud so again you
kind of see lots and lots of math
equations to make this happen and a lot
lots of kind of Integrated Systems that
need to talk to one another things that
happen on different scales etc etc um
and then kind of just maybe a history
lesson um kind of the evolution of these
models okay so in basically my time from
grad school till I guess I have to
extend this graph to today these models
that we use to to simulate what the
climate's going to look like in the
future have really evolved a lot in
terms of their complexity and also the
components of the system that factor
into it early on here we had the
atmosphere the model didn't even know
about the ocean basically
it wasn't until you know really we moved
into the early 90s that the ocean was
actually part in an interactive part of
the model and as we move today you can
see the whole range of things the carbon
cycle is affected so as we warm the
tundra and the meth thing gets released
that's something that the model knows
about it's you know it's interactive
it's dynamic in the model now as opposed
to something I have to specify or guess
at the
model um so the model works on a bunch
of grids basically Global Climate models
have um a resolution on the order the
the latest kind of state of the art
models as a round number a degree of
latitude by a degree of longitude for
these grids the models know about One
value for these boxes right so there's
one value of temperature for a box
there's one value of elevation for a box
so basically it's an average over that
one Dee by one Dee um M grids go up into
the atmosphere G go down into the ocean
um sometimes the grid size varies so if
we want to um if we want to specify
processes maybe near the surface of the
ocean that occur in a showerer level the
boxes might be a little bit narrower
there than they are in the deep ocean
where it really doesn't matter over
hundreds of kilometers of depth you can
say the same thing in the atmosphere you
know some some surface soil layers so
basically working on boxes and you know
maybe even here I'm going to mention
clouds because I mean clouds are clearly
one of the biggest sources of
uncertainty because they fall between
the cracks we have these large grid
boxes in the gcms the physics are well
represented at those scales kilometers
hundreds of kilometers maybe but when we
look at something like clouds to get the
physics right we need to be on
micrometers you know 10us 6 as opposed
to 10 the 3 or something like that so a
very hard mismatching scale to get the
physics right and say something like a
cloud in have a top climate mod and also
clouds tend to occur on smaller scales
than these grid boxes um so kind of to
put this into perspective in this graph
I think we're going to come back to this
graph but look at the red dots so
basically if this is the United States
um in a typical climate model the big
red dots are the grid points so there
are there's essentially one maybe you
can argue two grid points over the state
of New York um if we look at the United
States and a typical State ofthe art
today present day climate model it looks
something like this those are its
borders whoops missing Florida um most
of the Great Lakes are missing there's
one GD there's one grid point over Lake
Superior so that's what the Lakes look
like to the models so you can see a very
crude representation at the GCM scale
and this is a reflection of topography
again if I go back every the model only
knows about one value for each of these
red dots so it's not surprising that the
Rocky Mountains look like a hump as
opposed to the Rocky Mountains um and
actually notice very little here over
the appalation GCM
scale so um typically what is done
nowadays is something that's called
downs scale so it's nice to have these
Global models it's nice to say boy the
global temperature is going to change by
this much over the next 100 years but
when we start to talk about impacts and
adaptations you know people really don't
care about these large GCM grid boxes
they want to know well I pick Europe up
here basically what's happening in New
York what's happening in the wine
growing region of New York so really
kind of really really focused um type
data so the way we do that is
downscaling and there's really two ways
that we can downscale climate model data
we can do it statistically basically
using regression of some statistical
model to link the large scale climate
model variables to the local scale
climate conditions that we're interested
in or we can do it dynamically we can
use a finer resolution model we can feed
the data from a large scale climate
model into a finer scale what we call
RCM is a regional climate model um and
let actually the physics do that um both
have their strengths and weaknesses and
really state-of-the-art is I can't tell
you one is better than the other there's
probably some reasons why you'd want to
do it statistically there's other
reasons why youd want to do it
dynamically so it really just depends
neither of these value neither of these
have really evolved enough to say yep
think maybe doing it dynamically is the
better way to do it but in the end you
really don't see that in terms of that
um so again a few words of uncertainty
and basically there's a whole Cascade of
uncertainty when we're looking at maybe
going from what the climate is going to
be like to or what the climate is to uh
what are the impacts going to be or how
should we adapt right we have think of
the graphs that I've showed so far we
have uncertainty into how our CO2
emissions are going to evolve so
basically what's Society going to look
like and how given that society looks
like something how is our CO2 emissions
going to evolve right we could still be
a very economically driven Society very
consumeristic Society but maybe we're
going to do it with Renewables as
opposed to fossil fuels um or maybe
we're going to become a more sustainable
society and we have a blend of fuels as
opposed to going totally to Renewables
and clearly uncertainties in the global
models clearly uncertainties in the down
scaling techniques um you know if I gave
you a set of downscale data what would
you do with it you probably put it into
some model of some plant pathogen or
some yield model or something like that
and hopefully unless unless I'm mistaken
know your models have uncertainties as
well right so there's another level of
uncertainty there and then the
adaptation response okay yeah maybe the
plant's going to respond this way and
then I have to adapt to it and there's
uncertainties that adaptation model so a
whole Cascade of uncertainties from you
know you think this is uncertain by the
time you get down to year might say I
forget about it but that's not the case
um all right so real quickly how is this
downscaling done and there's a number of
different ways to do it perhaps the most
simple is called the Delta method and
really this is what we used in the in
the New York State climate assessment
the climate report um it's really based
on the mean and really what it does is
it takes the climate model temperature
for some historical period so these
climate models aren't only run into the
future they're also run into the past
all right they run backwards all right
so the physics are allowed to run
backwards so the climate model has some
estimate of what the climate looked like
say in this base period and then it also
has a projection for what it looks like
say at the end of the century and all
the Delta is very simple it's the mean
it's the difference in the mean of those
two distributions the historical model
distribution and the future and then to
downscale the data um I maybe uh find
the station I'm interested in or the
grid I'm interested in if I have an
observed grided database and I say all
right here's where I am in this base
period I add the Delta to it and that's
what I have in the future so again not
rocket science here so basically all it
is is saying the climate model Chang by
this much in the mean through time I'm
going to add that to the current value
um this is what we used in the New York
State assessment you can do this monthly
you can use it daily if you use this
daily I might say well the climate model
in July increased its bean temperature
by 5 Dees and if I want to get a daily
series of the future I might go back to
July's at a station in the future and
every day add 5 Dees to that temperature
so I don't change the variance at all I
don't change the day-to-day change I
just make everything
former this is what's done
sometimes um obviously that's not
state-of-the-art and pretty much most of
the statistical
downscaling kind of a busy graph here
but it you know what you might expect it
takes some set of predictor variables it
may be temperature at that large GCM
scale then it develops some type of a
relationship using a statistical model
either a regression an analog approach a
neural network or something like that to
derive a statistical relationship a
statistical model to get you the down
scale value so you might start off with
temperature at the GCM scale do your
statistics and end up at with
temperature in IA let's say or um maybe
instead of temperature I take the bigger
picture I I I become a meteorologist and
I say okay this is what the weather map
look like this is what the heights are
this is what the amount of moisture in
the atmosphere is and I use those as
predictors through some statistical
technique and I get temperature or
snowfall or precipitation or
humidity that you know for for that
everyone get that basic concept there I
guess all right and then the last way to
do this is dynamically so really here we
have our model at the GCM scale we have
our finer resolution Regional climate
model it has some
boundary and really it's the GCM that
feeds in and gives this model its
boundary conditions okay so the data
that's input to this finer scale which
might know at least in my picture hear
about the Alps or the United States
about the Rockies or the Adera or the
Great Lakes right because remember the
Great Lakes really aren't the climate
model um this Regional model is able to
resolve that scale the boundary
conditions feed into the edges kind of
keeps it you know is the Northeast in a
trough is the Northeast in a ridge on a
given day day at the large scale and
then how does that play out at the finer
scale so we look at it this way here's
the typical us boundary in a regional
climate model so again you can see that
increase in resolution we kind of have
Florida um kind of see most of the Great
Lakes although I would argue Ontario and
Eerie aren't really represented no
Finger Lakes okay so again not kind of
keeping the scale there and you can
obviously see a lot more more uh
definition of the Rocky Mountains and
kind of hard to see here but also an
indication of the appalachi so again
it's getting that physics right right we
can solve the physics of what's going to
happen with changes in elevation and
things like that much better on a much
finer scale here than we might have in
the global
sense um all right so no matter what we
do in terms of
downscaling we're not going to get it
perfect so there's there's bias um so
this is an example of um bias and
actually some downscale extreme rainfall
that we're working on so this is
dynamically downscaled each of the
colored box plots represent um a
different combination of a global model
and a different Regional model and
basically what I'm trying to predict
here I think it is the I think it's the
100-year storm actually in terms
of and you can see some
combinations do pretty pathetic you know
they're they're 25 or% lower than they
should be um some combinations are spot
on okay in the mean the width of the box
plot represents how well do these models
work for about 150 stations in New York
so the scale of these box plots are New
York and basically the spread represents
how well can these downscaling
techniques represent the the changes in
extreme rainfall at all of these
stations so again even though these
might look pretty good in Median on
average no bias um you know there is a
fair amount of spread in the Box CL you
know on the order of maybe
10%
um here's a different approach same type
of thing but with an analog approach a
statistical approach and you can see
here is might be an example where you
might argue boy those look a lot better
in this case they're a lot more closed
the bias tends to be less the spread of
the box plots particularly with this
statistical method seems to be a little
bit less kind of gives an idea of I
think not only the uncertainty in doing
this but also that really no one way is
better than the other in this case and
we have to look at a number of different
ways to kind of come up to say what kind
of down scale am I get use for
this um so here is the latest
state-of-the-art downscale temperature
projection for the Northeast it's a NASA
product it downscales the climate of 2
yeah 2100 in July at 800 M so if I said
boy should I you know you want to use
this product in your in your research
what would you say you know is this like
state-ofthe-art
or I'm going to say or is it you know
fire beware okay so the point that I
want to make here yeah it's easy to
downscale to whatever scale you want but
you know there's only so much data you
can you know I can slice and dice the
current observations down to 100 met if
I want are you going to believe you know
that value I worked with Alan Lao a
little bit and his temperature sensors
in the finger LS you know just looking
at Vineyards and slopes down to the
lakes and know even with the data how
hard it was to try to model that and
here okay yeah I can you can you know go
on the web and find this downscale
product at you know a resolution of
eight football fields and um you know
you can believe it or not and just as an
example again with these downscale
products um this is no different from
really what we do in weather forecasting
okay so you know you watch Dave iorn or
Wing Mahar God forbid or something like
that and you know essentially you know
when they're looking at what goes on in
the fingerlakes or in the Great Lakes
they're really doing a form of this
dynamical downscaling they're taking a
large scale weather forecasting model
and then they have a regional model that
knows about the finger legs knows about
the gra legs and things like that so my
example is um since it rained on
Saturday morning I put together my talk
Saturday morning and you know this is a
this is a weather forecasting model for
Saturday morning I was thinking how much
did it was you know remember it rained
Saturday morning so basically what I did
was how much did the model predict was
going to fall in IA versus how much it
actually did so this example spot on
okay spot on but enough oops
ah God darn it M up anyway but if you
know it's spot on in itha but if I look
say a different spot if I look up at the
Cena the model was predicting
0.55 it only got 006 so again this idea
the finest of the models that you look
at you're still going to have you know
they're not going to Bea so this this
increase in resolution doesn't
necessarily mean higher RS so anyway now
back to the future so um what is the
temperature going to look like so a
number of slides that come out of the
national assessment basically and um a
lot of them are laid out sort of like
this where the slides on your left um
labeled A2 are a high emission scenario
it's really that business as usual
scenario where we double CO2 over the
next 50 years quadruple over the next
100 years the B1 scenario is a lower
emission scenario it's one where we kind
of peak emissions midcentury and then
come back down so that by 2100 we're
about where we are today about eight or
nine megat tons of carbon per
year and then the row across the top is
mid-century kind of the the period from
from 2040 to 2070 and then the bottom is
the end of the century 2070 to basically
2100 so if we look across the Northeast
um you know the big contrast mid-century
again doesn't matter really what we do
in terms of admissions end of the
century matters a lot a lot of red in
the high emissions not a lot in the low
emissions this big you know the bright
red here essentially um switching back
and forth in units I'm sorry that's a
pitfall of of doing meteorology um
you're on the order of 8 or n degrees
fahit warmer at the end of the century
than we are today on average a average
temperature by midcentury maybe about 4°
warmer than we under the low emiss
scenario a little bit better maybe about
two versus maybe about five there um now
unfortunately when the national
assessment was done it was done on an
older generation of climate models so
the newer model runs for the for the
International Panel on climate change
were being run at the time the US did
the national assessment so kind of
looking at this and I know this is not a
great graph but what this is intended to
show is the difference between the older
generation climate models that the
national assessment is based on versus
the early runs of these new models that
are going into the
ipcc and if you look at this graph uh
especially across the Northeast it's
kind of yellow and orange yellow and
orange are a number greater than one so
what that says the newer models show an
increase in the warming as opposed to
the the older models by about a
degree um the warming projected occurs
across all seasons so this idea a of
looking at the past observations and
saying most of the warming has been in
the winter doesn't play out as we go
into the future as we go into the future
the amount of warming in the winter is
really just about the same if not a
little bit less than what we see in the
summer um we look at very hot days in
the future they get hotter so these are
the number of days that have a maximum
temperature greater than
95 so if I kind of here in our neck of
the woods that number goes up by about
four to five days and you know most
people who've lived here in Ithaca know
that a day above 95 is not unheard of
but but very very rare but what this is
saying is that on average by kind of
mid-century we can expect about four or
five of those days you know if you're
down here in mind NE of the woods where
I grew up in New Jersey you're talking
about you know 14 or 15 more of those
days um per
year um very cold days become a lot less
so kind of a mnom here in color but if I
look up across the North country in the
adex these are days with the minimum
temperature below 10° F and we see a
decrease of about 20 to 25 of those days
so these very very cold days become less
again that whole distribution shifting
over um free speed period increases by
about three weeks by the middle of the
century middle end of the
century um relative humidity again sorry
for a fuzzy graph but um notice the dots
the blue lines are the zero lines so
basically here this is the western North
America this is Central North America um
sorry the study that I swiped and didn't
reference for this didn't do anything in
the Eastern us but as you can see most
of the projections across of changes in
temperature are again showing decreases
in relative humidity the idea is the
temperature continues to go up and the
absolute level of moisture continues to
go up but they don't match up and you
end up with relatively lower uh
R um these are um average rainfall so
rainfall goes up by about 5 6% go
through the century um it gets even
worse in the new generation models
actually goes up by about 10% more than
the older generation we showing um
interesting though the majority the line
share of that increas is winter we look
at summer in all of the models and all
of the scenarios it's basically a wash
saying you know it can easily go it can
easily get higher or lower in the
summertime so essentially you can say
summer States about like it is but all
of this increase in rainfall is really a
winter time phenomenon which again
meteorologically makes a lot of sense if
you kind of think about the winters
getting warmer and being able to hold
more water vapor and and have big
rainfall events um we look at these
extreme rainfall events like two 3in
rainfall events in the frequency of
these go up actually tremendously across
New York State we're seeing a you know a
percent change on the order of 25 almost
30% in some cases I really think this
this idea of extrem rain fall playing
out is a big impact for not only the
Northeast but particularly uh New York
in that case um again this is some of
our work and it's actually showing the
100-year storm um basically the amount
of rainfall you would expect to see in a
100-year storm um 100-year storm for IA
is about a 6 in rainfall in the day and
what we're projecting kind of by the end
of the century for that to go up on
about 40% so know 100e storm 40% more
rainfall if you do that the other way
around a storm you would expect to occur
now every 100 years occurs about every
60 or 50 years um so a big change in the
frequency of these
events um dry period length um kind of
you often hear that we're going to have
more shortterm drought and that kind of
plays out for the southern part of the
region but as we move across New York
This Kind of Blue
um blue to Brown transition is
essentially zero so this idea of shorter
term prolonged dry periods with no rain
really doesn't play out but that doesn't
necessarily say that the amount of rain
you get in these events kind of goes up
it's just that it rains right so the
period of time between rainfall events
so you can imagine even if this doesn't
change but if your rainfall events are a
half an inch versus a tenth of an inch
that makes a big difference in terms of
the
a so so I think that was all right so
kind of being almost right on time just
some closing thoughts um but the first
thing is um
uncertainty downscale projections are
not fact they're a guide they're a gauge
they're the best we have so I'm not
saying don't use them but I'm saying
Beware of the uncertainty and then also
kind of my pet peeve finer resolution
does not be better um just means we
diced it a little biter
um basically all of the downscaling
represents changes in mean really
doesn't talk about changes in the
variant and these are actually some runs
from actually the last National
assessment that first started to look at
changes in variant and these are an
average over a bunch of models and say
basically in some seasons in some
periods of time the variance goes up in
others it goes down
maybe you you looked at this and you had
at least one kind of cohesive message on
this is well maybe summer and fall have
higher variants and maybe winter has
lower variant point that I want to make
is don't necessarily read into this too
much because if I had a different graph
and actually showed the variance change
in the different models um you know
basically they're all over the place and
these are just the means that are coming
out that and this is very important I
mean we're actually doing some work on
Frost risk and kind of looking at the
risk of frost damage to crops as the
average temperature goes up and
essentially as the average temperature
goes up the risk of frost doesn't really
change that much all it does is it
happens at the different time of year so
there's still I don't know if you know
if there's a 10% chance that this stage
Gets Zapped by Frost
currently there's still a 10% chance
that that happens in the future instead
of happening in May it might happen in
April in that case so basically the
whole cycle is kind of just earlier and
earlier ear but if you superimpose a
change in variance on that actually a
very small change in variance something
on the order of five or 10% you get a
huge difference in Frost risk so here's
an example of an potential impact of
climate change some people say Frost
risk is going to go up under climate
change which I don't necessarily agree
with in kind of doing this to see that
it's really something that's being
driven by the V changes in variant as
opposed to changes in mean something
that we don't have a very good handle on
particularly in our downscale data and
so basically just to leave it you know
obviously the climate is changing uh we
have to adapt um again remember our
emissions are obviously important for
future Generations in the magnitude of
the event but regardless of what we're
going to do um we got to ad that to so
work out pretty well so I think we have
some time for a few
questions this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu